- Because the biographies
of the other panelists
are all listed on the
registration website,
you have access to their
distinguished achievements.
I'm going to introduce them
in the briefest possible way,
and have them take seven minutes
to make an introductory statement.
After which, we will have a discussion
and hopefully allow questions
from the floor as well.
First
is Ma Thida,
Who is a surgeon and novelist.
A large figure in the
international PEN movement.
And...
Very well known as an activist.
And so let me turn over the
floor to her for seven minutes.
- Thank you, everybody, and
I think it's very hard to cover
what's happening right now in my country
in seven minutes, but I'll try my best.
And first of all, I would like to focus on
the governance issue.
After the coup, the
military, it cannot show
it's qualified enough
to govern the country,
especially in Magway
division, Sagaing division
and Chin states, of course.
And then the Chin state and the Yangon,
it's not as the whole region,
but especially in the city area.
At the same time, they
are trying to control,
through the village level
administrators on the ground
for the majority of the country.
In that case, from the revolution side,
people defense forces are trying to focus
on these local administrator,
as they are precursors to send
all the information to the...
Soldiers or the military; Whom to arrest,
whom to kill, et cetera.
That's why the current situation
about the governance issue is pretty much
in a question mark.
And PDF focuses on
killing this kind of the,
local village level, administrators,
naming them as Dalan, the informer.
So in terms of the
legislature, the military,
since the coup, they don't care about...
Either initiation or the
amendment of any law,
apart from the cybersecurity law.
In that case, right now,
the People Defense Forces
and the revolution people
focusing on destroying the Mytel tower.
From the very beginning,
since the military do the
internet shut down deliberately
in the whole country.
But right now, focusing on
this hard to govern area,
they do the international (indistinct).
And right now in Sagaing,
and in part of the Chin state.
But at the same times the PDF
focuses on the Mytel tower,
and then the Mytel owned by the military,
partly owned by Vietnamese
business company.
Then the Mytel started saying
about internet shut down
will marginally interfere
for the sake of the
information, et cetera.
Even though the military
introduced the cybersecurity law,
and all the...
The white list introduction and etcetera,
as soon as they took the power.
But NUG has been doing
quite a lot of the...
Law enforce, not,
law amendment or the initiation.
Recently the NUG started
the income tax law,
that the amendment of the income tax law
in order to have more
donation, indirect donations,
and from the business people.
Rich business people and Italy...
Citizens, they normally don't
take part in the revolutions
through the protest, nor through the
any other ways.
But they have the money,
they can indirectly
support the revolution.
This is also very, pretty much,
the ground situation on the legislature.
In terms of rule of law...
The killing, and arbitrary arrests,
looting, asking for the ransoms for the...
The arrested of people,
or the dead bodies,
the arsons they're
burning the whole village,
and bombing.
This is going on from the military side,
and they sometimes accuse
the People Defense Forces
as the corporate for that.
Even though they already
have their own version
of the civilian...
Violence attackers, under
the name of (indistinct),
something like that.
But the way they look
at the rule of law issue
is for example recently...
The daughter of the hiring
military officer has been shooted
at very late night when she was
driving back from somewhere.
And the security forces stopped
her and she didn't stop,
and she kept driving and
she was shooted to death.
And in that case, the military supporters
started saying that, "Oh, you see,
our military is good enough.
They don't care whoever betrayed the law,
they are taking action.
They never ever think
this should not be done,
the killing to those people
without knowing them...
It's arbitrary killing.
But the way of the concept
of the military supporter
on rule of law is something like that.
But at the same times we have so much
concern about the...
For longer term problems.
If everybody just thinking
of the UMP revolution is the solution.
But recently I was so
happy to learn the CDM,
the Civil Disobedience Police.
They started making an announcement,
saying that they beg the
pardons from the people
for the institutional...
Wrongdoing, during the
Saffron Revolution in 2007,
even though they are not the real culprit,
or real committer of this crime.
They feel the institution
has a responsibility,
and they tried to beg the
pardon from the people.
The way the revolutions grew...
Thinking on the issue of rule of law,
is quite promising to me in that case.
And yes, the last thing is
all about the resilience
and the resistance.
It's not just from the people,
and we learning more and more,
the soldiers are defecting.
And the way the...
Revolution people,
resistance is...
More like...
Just trying to stop
the military data ship,
not focusing on the...
Violence for the longer run.
So that we'll cover.
Thank you, thank you.
- Thank you Ma Thida.
The next speaker (clears
throat) is Katun Myint,
a professor in political
science at Carlton College.
He was a student leader
in the 1988 uprising...
As a PhD from Indiana.
Wrote a book on international treaties
concerning the (indistinct) and the Rhine.
And he is a founder of
the Mutual Aid Myanmar,
that has gathered lots of
contributions to help...
Striking public sector workers.
Katun, please.
- Thank you very much Jim,
and thank you to all of you who
are listening to this panel.
And I will offer two broad
historical related frameworks,
two broad frameworks
related to, or rooted,
in Burmese history.
And then one philosophical
reflection on the current crisis.
I'll start with the first one,
the first one is related to
China and Burma relation.
And that has to go back to
the end of Sino Burmese war...
At the end of 1769.
One emperor of Qin dynasty, Qin Long,
decided to end the forth war,
attempting to annex Burma.
He issued a proclamation
to his military leaders,
in that military leaders program mission.
This is what a Qin Long said,
and quote, beginning of the quote,
"When you sent the army and in tech,
there should be a fewer
soldiers lightly armed.
They should take advantage of
the enemies lack of readiness
to just destroy their crops.
And kill a few and take a few prisoners.
The purpose is no more
than to disturb them,
but not really a war of big scale."
So that heading, which the Qin Long issue,
still in play today in terms of creating
buffer zones on the Thai-Burma.
Sorry, Myanmar and China border.
Wa ethnic groups, Chin and (indistinct),
and AA, which was born in KIA area.
All play in that game of the end of a war.
But what Qin Long wanted was
a permanent war in Burma,
where have no peace can be settled.
And so today's ethnic conflict.
And then the march to the
federal open inclusive framework
is a struggle here China
has posed on Burma.
Wa, (indistinct), and
all other ethnic group
that has not been explicitly saying
that we support NUG.
NUG has been supported
by people and so on.
That framework is pretty important here,
because endless war is what China wanted,
that is happening in Myanmar,
and it is happening now.
So second thing that he did
was on February 6th, 1770,
he issue economic (indistinct)
against the Burmese king.
This might be perhaps the
first economic sanction
imposed by a country
against another country
in the world history.
It is certainly the first
economic sanction issue in Asia,
Asian continent.
In that economic session, his ethic set,
I'm going to quote him again,
"As for the matter of trait,
the Myanmar bandits eager
to exchange with China.
This is shown clearly in
several letters they sent.
Fortunately, I have foreseen this,
and I ordered repeatedly that
they could only ask for it
after they submit to us.
In short, no trade with
China will be allowed
before the arrival of
their surrender letter.
This method is the best way
to control the foreign barbarians."
So that was his ethic on this
issue on February 6th, 1770,
against Burma.
And so that trait practice
is still useful today,
to understand the Chinese
investment in Burma,
the economic influence
that China is exercising
and maneuvering this crisis in Myanmar.
In fact, to support the
first goal that they had,
which is just basically,
Burma should never get rich,
never have peace.
And that is Chinese foreign
policy rooted in 1770,
and it is continuing today.
And so those two frameworks
are very important for us
to understand why the Coup, why Mueang
and military leaders are
really totally relying on China
at the UNSC and all of area
of international affairs.
So that's the first one.
Second one I want to talk about
is the history of state building in Burma.
The history of state building
in Burma need to be understood
to understand why the
struggle for federalism,
inclusive open federalism,
is so difficult.
The first...
The unifier of Burma is
as we know Anawrahta,
and then the Bayinnaung.
And then the Alaungpaya.
And these three King's statues
are erected in Naypyidaw,
and now on the China-Burma border city
is beginning to be built to have that
three statue of these Kings.
What they did and what they
created as a unifying Burma
was a Burman ethnocentric state.
Legitimized by Buddhist stock train,
which supported by the sangha,
which is a more of a materialist sangha
than the spiritual and philosophical.
And more actually what
Buddha really taught
to understand the world.
That materialist Buddhism,
or materialist Buddhists,
good examples are,
current (indistinct) The
Nationalist Buddhist monks.
All of them are play in
legitimizing the state,
the (indistinct), the full group.
Which is because the
three Burman empire...
Have failed to build the Burman state.
Now (indistinct) and military leaders
are attempting to build that
state with 2008 constitution.
And that was their document to
begin unifying Burman state,
and that state failed and by design
because the CDM participant protesters,
EAO's do not want that
kind of state survive
or thrive in Burma.
They want that state to fail.
It's a state failure in
Burma, is it by design?
Society is resilient and
robust against that state.
And that is really good news for open
and inclusive federalism into the future.
We can get that into detail in a point.
And the final point that
I wanted to offer is
my reflection on the current violence.
The violence that Ma Thida
have already spoken about
generally, what were happening.
You can imagine seven years old daughters
being shot at on the lap
of the father in Mandalay.
You can imagine a poet
killed and open his chest,
and taking out organs from him.
That will be the poet Khet Thi from Naga.
And the crimes against humanity,
and the scale of violence, if you will.
Dirty creativity of the
violence by the Myanmar military
is stunning.
The world is experiencing and
seeing it every day happening
unpacked in Burma.
The question for political
scientists, especially,
and maybe even international
lawyers especially, is
is there a proper violence,
and is there a proper role
of violence in political establishment?
And I think for us international
relations scholars,
just war theory, rooted
in Hindu tradition.
Philosophy offer some
kind of route to actually
imagine that there might
be proper violence,
and there might be legitimate violence.
And there might be just war
that we could consider, especially if...
The world is moving
toward a more inclusive,
open liberal framework
of democratic world.
Against Chinese and Russian
order of centralized order.
If we want to really
open up to the protest,
or somewhat imagine the agency
and freedom of individuals
around the world.
In the world order that
is coming into the future,
we might have to rethink
about the way in which
the utopian peace is imagined.
So that's all I have to offer.
- Thanks Katun.
The next speaker is David Thang Mo.
He's a PhD candidate in
history and theological studies
at the Ashbury Theological
Seminar in Kentucky.
And by going to his website this morning,
I realized that he's the
author of dozens of articles
on ethnic conflict, on religion.
On Buddhist nationalism, and so on.
Some of which I put under my belt,
but it's quite an impressive reading list.
And I...
Admire what he's had to say
in several panels that we've
jointly participated in.
David, you have seven minutes.
- Thank you so much for
your kind introduction
Professor Jim Scot.
And it's very good to see you again after
sharing a panel
(indistinct) in South Korea,
I will be speaking from the
perspective of the ethnic
and religious minority.
So speaking from that,
it's not possible to ignore
Buddhist nationalism,
and all the ethnic identity,
or maybe even ideology conflict.
I just want to focus on that topic today.
I would like to briefly touch on
the politics of religions, and the origins
and movement of Buddhist
Nationalism our country.
Buddhist Nationalism is
nothing new in Myanmar,
it has been rooted in the
British colonial period,
in the 19th century.
But the way that Buddhist
Nationalism emerged
is different from each
department, or each movement.
In the British colonial period,
it emerged as the anti-Western influence.
I would like to prefer the
word anti-Western influence,
instead of anti-foreign influence.
If we put it anti-foreign
influence we can say that,
well, now the military
garment is related to China,
and Russia, and all this things like that.
I prefer the word Buddhist Nationalism,
emerged in the British colonial period
as the anti-Western influence.
It was during that time that
the Burma Independence Army,
which is the current
military garment, obviously,
that is the rule of the movement.
It was formed to fight against
the British colonial period,
and they always claimed that that is how
they came to gain
independence from British.
Let's move to the second movement,
which is (indistinct)
from the first movement.
In the post-colonial period,
or what I'll call it
post-independent period,
the Buddhist Nationalism
in Myanmar emerged
as the anti-Burma, or maybe,
the anti-non-Buddhist movement, right?
For example, U Nu make a famous slogan,
what do you call it?
Amyo, barthar, thathanar.
If you are not a Buddhist in Myanmar,
you will face some discrimination's.
There are at least three
main characteristics
of that Buddhist Nationalism.
First political domination
is very obvious,
and the second is that the
ethnic cultural lsf;sk relations.
So the ethnic minority cultures
has been as it's related
to the dominant Buddhist cultures.
And then the third is the
religious discrimination,
so if you are not a Buddhist
you will face some discrimination's
in many ways in Myanmar.
And so what I would like to
put here is that there is
the concept flag and faith, right?
This the Buddhist led military government
imagined the politics in Myanmar, India,
Buddhist way of thinking.
That is what happened
especially in this
post-independent period,
what I'll call it, make
Buddhism great again.
Which has been very,
very obvious in Myanmar.
And then of course some of these,
the military government
leaders are influenced
by Donald Trump's slogan definitely.
Make America great again, right?
So they also use make
Buddhism great again,
because they feel that
Buddhism was declined
during the British colonial period.
So that's how they feel.
Now let's move to the third movement,
what I will call it old
Buddhist Nationalism
in the new coup.
In this movement, it's slightly different
from the previous two movement.
In this movement it's not just
the ethnic identity conflict,
but also the ideology conflict.
That means the conflict
is not just between,
the majority of them are Buddhist
and ethnic minority group.
But among the Buddhist also
have some conflict, right?
That is something
important to remember here,
so Buddhism against
Buddhism that is obvious.
And then leadership, dictatorship
against democracy movement.
As well as the Burma against the Burma.
That means the conflict
becomes bigger than
the second one and the third one.
Let me touch on these
opportunities and challenges.
The rise of this, the new coup,
create the opportunity of inter-religious
and inter-ethnic solidarity among these...
Protestors.
If (indistinct).
But in this current movement
people from different religions
and different ethnic groups come together
and share their
inter-religious solidarity,
or maybe a unity.
Of course, the question
is how deep that unity is?
But at least we can see
that this the coup create
the opportunity of inter-religious
and inter-ethnic solidarity
for the democracy movement.
Especially that movement is led by
the generation Z, or maybe
the young generation.
You can see it in this picture.
One on the left is (indistinct).
And the right one is ethnically Shani...
It is dharma.
And so they just try to
bridge their religious
and ethnic divides to
confront the military coup
as their common enemy.
This is something important to remember
with this current movement.
So here is my question,
eight months into the coup,
what is the state of democracy movement
earlier Ma Thida and Tun
has covered a lot of things.
And let me briefly touch on that
from the perspective of
the ethnic minority issue.
In my view, in these
eight months of the coup,
there are two strategies
that the people are using
today in Myanmar.
First is a non-violence in the beginning,
they protest on the street
in a non-violent way.
But the military government
used a violent crackdown
on the peaceful protesters.
And then maybe sometime in March,
they start thinking about how they should
themselves self-defense.
So in that case they use a violent way,
and especially in Mindat
where I'm from originally,
they formed this PDF,
People Defense Force.
Which has been changed to a CDF later on,
to make their chin, this
resistant movement unique.
So that is something that we can see.
In this second strategy,
we can also see that the way
the current movement is also
trying to go beyond Aung San
Suu Kyi method of nonviolence.
And we don't know whether
Aung San Suu Kyi might
agree with that or not,
we don't know.
But what we can say here is that
the current movement is
trying to try to go beyond
Aung San Suu Kyi method of non-violence.
- You have to stop soon David.
- Yes, okay, here...
Let me go here to the...
To the third point.
My question is, do the ethnic minorities
and ethnic majorities
share the same visions?
I think the answer is yes,
but which they can further argue that
the ethnic majority have a
vision of freedom from the coup.
But the ethnic minority
have a double visions,
freedom not only from the coup,
but also from the Buddhist nationalism.
That is something significant.
And let me move to the last point.
Does Myanmar have the future of democracy?
If no, why?
And if yes, how?
We might have different obedience,
but in my view, yes, the answer is yes.
But we need two movement,
not only internal movement in Myanmar,
but also the external movement.
And international communities
cooperating with internal movement.
In that case, I will urge
the international community
to recognize NUG.
And second, I would urge
the international community
to advocate for freedom of
Myanmar people in many ways.
And third to financially
support the CDM strikers,
and IDP people.
And I believe that the next
big US ambassador Scot Marciel,
will talk a little bit
more about this issue.
Thank you.
- Thank you, David.
Next, let me recognize Scot Marciel,
a career of Foreign Service Officer.
Who has spent most of his
career in Southeast Asia,
was ambassador to Indonesia,
ambassador to Burma,
and ambassador to ASEAN.
Scot, you have seven minutes.
- Thanks very much.
And thanks for letting me join this panel
as sort of the outsider
among the four speakers,
since the other three,
obviously are from Myanmar,
and I'm very clearly not.
But have had the pleasure
of spending some time there.
I'd like to frame my comments a little bit
in a big picture policy way.
The way I look at this situation,
the Myanmar military, the Tatmadaw.
As we know, around the
country from 1962 to 2010, 11,
before it started loosening
up and allowing reforms.
And in that roughly 50 year period,
they ran the country about as badly
as one can run a country in every respect.
Obviously there's rightly
been a huge amount of focus
on the conflict and
human rights violations,
and lack of freedom and democracy.
But they also managed to drive
the economy into the ground,
while destroying or nearly
destroying the health system,
the education system.
And actually exacerbating
the very ethnic conflicts
which David mentioned that the
rule was supposed to resolve.
You have that history,
and then you had the
period of roughly a decade
when the reforms began.
From when the reforms began in 2011, 12,
until the coup this year.
And in that period you
had a lot of reform.
You had significant increases in freedom,
you had a near consensus
on the need to move
toward a federal democracy.
In the period I was there, 2015 to 2020,
a lot of us focused and a lot
of the media attention focused
on the areas of continuing
disagreement and problem,
the Rohingya crisis.
The continuing conflict
and the lack of movement
on the peace process.
Continuing problems with lack of
full freedoms and human rights.
The military's continuing
human rights violations,
and so on.
But when I look back at it now,
all of those things were very real.
And there was very serious
challenges that the country
was confronting and still has to confront.
But in my view, there was
near consensus in the
country on one thing,
that the country had an
opportunity to move forward.
And it was moving forward
in fits and starts.
And everybody, just about everybody,
was adamant that the one thing
that they did not want to see
was a return to the bad
old days of military rule.
And so the coup on February 1st,
in addition to being completely
unjustified, illegitimate,
you name it.
It basically met instant opposition
from almost the entire country.
Because of course, people
didn't want to have
their freedoms taken
away and their democracy,
flawed as it might have been, taken away.
But also I think because
people saw their hope
and their opportunity for a
better future being taken away.
And I think this helps explain
the incredibly widespread
resistance, peaceful and otherwise,
to a return to military rule.
This is not...
Some opposition movement,
this is really the country of Myanmar.
Ethnic Burma and ethnic
minorities pretty much together,
united in, what's in effect,
a national resistance
against military rule.
That is, I view,
is largely the equivalent
of occupying force.
In the sense that they have no legitimacy,
no popular support,
no real interest in helping
people live better lives.
It's striking the Tatmadaw
doesn't really care
how much people suffer.
It's almost unimaginable,
they not only impose their own suffering,
but weaponize COVID
and take other measures
that make it clear that they don't give a
damn about the people at all.
It's all about power for them.
Going forward,
I don't see the resistance
to the coup waning.
If anything, it will increase both, again,
peaceful means and non peaceful means.
The Tatmadaw given its history,
is unlikely to say, "Okay, well,
we'll just give up."
So sadly, I think, that
means for some time
we're going to see more
suffering, more violence.
And it is really important,
I think people are aware,
it is really important to
remember and to think every day
about the incredible
amount of human suffering
that's going on as a result of this coup
throughout the country.
The violence for sure,
people suffering from COVID
and not being able to get
adequate medical help.
People being displaced,
people losing their jobs,
going hungry.
Across the board it's just
a horrific humanitarian situation.
And I think it's important that the world
stay very focused on that.
And remember for this is not
just a political problem,
it's a problem of human,
it's a humanitarian crisis
and a problem of human suffering.
Going forward, looking
for a little bit further,
there's been this discussion or debate
about whether dialogue is needed.
Whether dialogue is appropriate
to try to resolve this problem.
And it's really tricky,
I think it's really
important to be careful
how we talk about this.
Because neither side is unlikely
to just give up or surrender.
At some point, probably,
there will be a need for
some kind of discussions
to hopefully find a way out of this.
But I think what's key is
that the conditions now
are not right for that.
The Junta's has shown no
interest in discussions,
they've completely ignored
and blown off ASEAN efforts to mediate.
They've shown no interest in this at all.
And my sense is that a lot of the people,
a lot of Myanmar people,
are not interested in these
discussions at this point now.
I think the hope for me for the future,
my belief is that what's
needed is for more pressure
on the Junta,
domestic pressure and
international pressure.
I don't believe they're going to be able
to restore stability and be
able to govern the country.
Okay?
And I think that what's needed is
intensive pressure over
a long period of time.
So that more and more military officers
understand that they
have no hope of winning.
And at that point they may be willing
to look for a way out
and make concessions,
which then could lead to
the beginning of dialogue.
I'll stop there.
- Thank you, Scot.
I wanted to add a couple of things just
into the mix for the
subsequent discussion.
The thing that does strike
me is that the Burma are now
suffering a form of...
Direct violence and oppression,
that the ethnic minorities
have been suffering
from since 1962.
And it's now come, if you
like, to the Burmese heartland.
And I, as a political scientist,
I don't know actually of another regime,
another military, that is
so universally despised.
This is not a rebellion by students
and cosmopolitan elites in the cities.
This is a rebellion by the
entire population; In villages,
rural villages.
And ethnic minority areas.
It is such a completely predatory regime
that has no popular base
and no popular support.
That's in a extraordinary
situation that in the long run,
this is a regime that
governs by sheer repression,
violence and terror.
And the interesting thing to me is that
the Tatmadaw...
Because it has its own education system,
its own...
Supply chain,
it has its own healthcare system,
it has its own pensions.
It insists that people
stay on the barracks.
It is probably the most
insulated military...
That the world has seen.
There may be a couple of other
examples a little like it,
but what's extraordinary
is that you could say
that the Tatmadaw does
not really live in Burma.
That is to say they are so insulated.
The horrific question is that,
that insulation insulates it
to some considerable degree.
How much, I don't know,
from internal defections, from a split,
and the officer core, and so on.
It looks, although there are defections,
there's no evidence that
you're going to have
a split in the military which
would lead to a situation,
I think, of perhaps more radical change.
I just wanted to put that on the table.
I wanted to open it both for let's add,
let's have the participants...
Chime in with their questions.
If your question is,
it would be good if your
question were directed
to one or another of the panelists.
Because then we would save
a good deal of the time,
rather than having four people answer.
I'll leave it to Chris
or to Erik to recognize
members of the audience
who have questions.
Can we have that again?
- [Announcer] There's
a question in the chat.
- Yeah, I see it.
Shall I address that question?
- Please.
- The question is how do you
think the role of ASEAN leaders
in coping, helping the
current situation in Myanmar.
I think you have within ASEAN
some governments that
seem extremely concerned
about the situation and
have been quite outspoken.
And then you have others
who have been less so,
so ASEAN seem divided.
I think you saw that
early effort back in April
to have this emergency meeting.
Which they came up with five points,
supposedly of agreement.
Although the Junta immediately
rejected them (chuckles),
within a day or two, I
believe, of the agreement.
And since then, I think ASEAN struggled
to find a way forward.
This is really harmful for ASEAN,
in addition to the suffering
of the Myanmar people.
Myanmar once again has returned to being
a really black mark for ASEAN,
as one of its members is
behaving in this horrific...
It's the military at least
behaving in this horrific fashion.
And I think ASEAN is really struggling
with how to deal with it.
They don't have really
measures, course of measures,
to employ to pressure Myanmar that much.
Their approaches normally one to try to
use the ASEAN family relationship
to try to win trust and have quiet talks,
and try to nudge.
But...
I don't know that anyone's ever succeeded
in quietly nudging this
military, the Tatmadaw.
They're not nudgeable, if that's a word.
I do think it's been a
little bit disappointing,
but I think it's important that
the ASEAN members keep pushing.
Because their own organization
is being undermined by what happens.
As well as the stability of
the region is being undermined
by the Junta and this coup.
I hope the ASEAN leaders
will keep looking for ways
to push the generals to rethink this.
- Next question.
- We have a question from (indistinct),
and then after that, there's
a question in the chat.
There's actually two
questions in the chat,
but they turn out to be the same person.
One came via email and one into the chat.
So I say we take the question
from (indistinct) first,
and then the question from the chat.
- Thank you Erik,
and thank you all for your comments.
I was going to type the
question in the chat box,
but I will state it here.
My question is directed to Dr Martina.
And it has to do with why does
the military of the regime,
(indistinct) in particular
as you've described,
bother with law at all.
When killing can be arbitrary
and the regime is governed by,
as Professor Scott
described, sheer repression,
violent and terror.
Why bother with law at all?
Thank you so much.
- Well, the concept behind forming,
or recruiting the soldiers
into the Myanmar Tatmadaw
has so many problems already.
The incentives to become the
military officer or the soldier
is not to protect the people.
That's very clear.
It's just to make them
having a privileged positions
among the others,
especially above citizens.
So the concept of the
Tatmadaw and the soldiers,
and military officer, is they...
Justify people...
To govern or to bully the citizens.
That's made more clear after the coup.
And after the coup the,
because of the economic sanctions,
and the other disobedience
from the citizens.
Military ISERP have not much income
to give
enough support to it's subordinates.
So especially on the ground, the soldiers,
are hunger.
And for that reason...
And then the rule of law never being
the issue for the military leaders.
That's they just let them
do whatever the arbitrary...
So much inhumane things to do.
And then I think another
thing is since the February,
there was no single day...
To get rest
for the soldiers and army men.
Because of either the peaceful protest,
or the UMP struggle is
going on everywhere,
all over the country.
This was the very hard for them,
for the nonstop action for
more than seven, eight months.
In that case, they just...
In...
The...
Deep bitterness and angers,
and they cannot think
of the better solutions
rather than making as much
as forces onto the citizens
to get cooling down.
Or to get afraid of doing
anymore, something like that.
So that one case.
And another case is they are
somehow addicted to either
alcohol or the drugs, the
methamphetamine by themselves,
the military soldiers and
the military officers.
That's why they are inhumane activities
is more or less related to.
That's why we have been
noticing a lot of the
fighting among each other,
after too much drinking alcohol.
The soldiers killed it's a...
Military officer, that's going on.
So I think the...
And then there will be the keep
ongoing the impunity issue,
the hiring military officer.
They never ever take any action
against their subordinates whatsoever.
Whatever they do, they do.
That's why the ransom
cases is almost like,
not just betrayed the citizens,
but also betraying itself,
the Tatmadaw itself.
They never let the military officer know,
but on the ground, they trying
to get as much as possible
from the Federalist members
of the arrested revolutionist.
That's how they get our money
during this kind of desperate period.
This is the period of
desperate for them too,
they cannot get rest, they
need to do something else.
Also they need to feed
for their family members,
and where else they can get money?
Their salary is pretty much granted
by the military regime too.
It's like this vicious cycle.
- I just wanted to add to that.
The pattern of absolute predatory robbery,
ransom, and so on,
much of which has to do with,
it's just the military
turned loose to make money
by kidnapping people and holding
their families, and so on.
I thought the question, however,
is worth pondering and I don't
have quite the answer to it.
And that's the question
of why did they bother
with this patina
with this fog
of legality?
The fact is that people were
charged under section 5-0-5.
- Yes.
- What's interesting to me is that
they do whatever they want to do.
But they require,
and it shows us the
legitimacy of the rule of law.
At some level, they have
to have this curtain,
in which it appears that there's
a section of the legal code
that they are using.
They have lawyers, they have judges.
And the whole point of a
successful dictatorship today
is to have the institutional
facade of a democracy,
including elections,
judges, and legal codes.
And to under that cover,
do whatever you want.
But it shows us actually
that behind all of this,
there's a tremendous
legitimacy of the rule of law,
and of democratic governance.
Because they have to fake it constantly.
Yes, next question.
The one was in the chat, I gather Erik.
- Yeah, Jim, thank you.
There's a series of questions
that congeal around the US
state department's position
on violence in Myanmar.
I'd like to broaden that
question just a little bit,
so that it's not only
directed to the ambassador,
but it's clearly on people's mind.
Tun had also mentioned the idea of,
"Is there a case of just war, right?
Or just violence."
And so, obviously the
questions would like to hear
what ambassador Scot Marciel has to say
about US position on that.
Which is maybe a tall task to
announce in a panel like this.
But I do think the topic of
violence when it's just, or not,
deserves some attention by the panel.
If all of you can reflect on that briefly,
I think that would be great.
- Scot?
- Thanks.
I'll try to address it
with a bit of a caveat.
First, I want to stress
it's former ambassador,
so I am not the ambassador to Myanmar.
And what I'm going to say is
absolutely my personal views,
it does not represent the views,
necessarily represent the
views of the US government,
or the state department.
I think...
First, it would be very
difficult for the US government
and many other governments
to come out and say,
"We support violence."
It's just...
And the way I look at this is that...
The military created this
situation with the coup,
and then when people tried
the peaceful approach
of civil disobedience and
peaceful protests, and so on.
The military responded with
horrific violence, as we know.
One can argue that people weren't really
left with the option of either dialogue
or a peaceful protest.
And so it's inevitable that some people
have taken other measures.
I think it's, again, it's
quite difficult for the
US government or other
governments, I think,
to come out and say we support violence.
But I think if you looked at
the totality of statements
from the US government
and the state department,
it's very clear that
they place responsibility
for what's happened on the military Junta.
And are very much in support of...
Of the people, and of efforts to restore,
I wouldn't even say restore.
Efforts to move the country
back onto a democratic path
with a government that respects
people and human rights.
- Anyone else want to comment?
- Well, I just want to add one point.
That's why I think from
the very beginning,
the people of Myanmar requesting
for having the heart to
be the responsibility,
to protect and that sense.
Still, I have so much concern about
the transition of justice
for the longer run.
For that reasons, we
seriously do have a presence
of the third party security
forces on the ground.
Otherwise there will be a non-stoppable
revanche conflict going on,
and that will be the end of our country.
For that reason I think the trust between
the current military and trust...
The current military and
the people of Myanmar
has already been finished.
It cannot be built again,
it's ever finished already.
That's why we seriously do
need the third party
security forces to...
Reestablish the rule of law
inside the country without them,
I think that's why we don't want any
of the governments in the war
to support the violence inside.
We want the international
community to help us
save Myanmar in terms of
making the
physical and literal...
Protection for the sake of the people.
The lives of the people, the
properties of the people.
Either way, it might be
through the UN platform,
or any way.
But, to be frank, because of this failure
a lot of our people have lost their trust
in any institutions,
including ASEAN and UN.
This is the very dangerous
for the longer run.
- But I wanted to add to that,
that actual intervention
by UN or foreign powers
is off the table.
I think we should start
with that assumption.
However, there are lots of things
that the international community can do.
One of them is to put even more pressure
on the nonpartisan delivery
of humanitarian aid
in Burma.
To communities that is not just
distributed by the Tatmadaw.
Another thing they can do
is to persuade the Thai
military to give the people
who were fleeing to Chiang Mai and Mae Sot
temporary protected status...
As political refugees.
So that they are not jumping to arrests
by the Thai military, and
being thrown back into Myanmar.
And presumably that same thing
goes for the 11,500 people
who were in Mizoram.
And who fled to the the West,
many of them Chin, as David knows.
It seems to me that short of intervention,
which will never happen,
a forcible intervention.
There are a lot of things that
the international community can do
that have not yet been accomplished.
- If I can add to the conversation,
there are two questions
that international community
can begin to ponder on.
One is considering the
type and amount of violence
that military is injecting on the public.
And we are daily reading Facebook feed,
Twitters and all that.
The question for international community
within the UN charter
chapter one, six and seven to consider is,
is the Myanmar military,
considering that it lost the trust.
And the legitimacy of
all types within Myanmar,
is Myanmar military becoming
the world's largest
terrorist organization.
Meaning a threat to not
just a domestic people,
meaning citizens of Myanmar .
But also the threat to the integrity
of the United Nations charter,
that enshrine the state sovereignty.
And is Myanmar military delivering,
insulting stakes over Myanmar,
and giving to another party?
Which would be to China,
the Myanmar military
might be actually now.
In fact, if you listen to the
several interaction between
peace minister (indistinct),
under the Taze administration
with the (indistinct) villagers.
Almen himself admitted
that Myanmar military
could not override whatever China's
want to do in the Myanmar.
Meaning that they had to listen to China.
So the question to that,
integrity of the UN charter,
integrity of the state sovereign
of Myanmar is under threat.
That question needs to be, I think,
at the UN security council level consider.
Second question is in
terms of the intervention,
and although type of
intervention the Myanmar,
the international
community might consider.
I think we might really be
critically now forced to,
in the case of Myanmar,
or the case of the way
of violence in Myanmar
by the military.
Is there a type of a war that is just?
In terms of guiding the
type of intervention
that need to be done to protect
the foundation of the
world, the community,
which is the individual,
agency and freedom.
If individual agency and
freedom become a dire threat,
and if our freedom, if I'm
pointed a gun on my forehead,
I should have a just
response to that person
who is going to kill me, who
is going to threaten my life.
So with that question,
I think that the extrapolating
the just war theory.
And understanding
September 7th defensive war
that NUG prepare, not
declare, I would say.
It's just preparation,
they use in emergency situation,
just for the people to prepare for it.
I think that kind of
questions are becoming
more relevant for the future diplomacy,
and the iteration order.
Because United State may not declare
that we support the violence.
But the United State have
invaded so many countries,
and tried to change the
history of the country.
If you think about it,
if you think of these
within the just war theory
that Obama eloquently
spoke at his Nobel Peace.
These are kinds of questions
we need to really consider
for international diplomats and scholars.
If we don't what we are doing is
we're basically listening or
watching that pendulum swinging
between Nazi type of fascism regime
to the democratic open type.
And that will be the world
history for maybe five millennia,
or eight millennia to come.
And that is a shame if we
are learning from books,
and thinking about these problems,
and the nature of this
violence that we cannot accept.
Even to see on the screen,
that is what at stake
for a lot of education,
and institution, and practitioners.
That's where I would add to.
- David, I know you've been
having internet troubles,
can you hear now?
And did you want to add
to this conversation
before we move on?
- [David] Can you hear me now?
- [Erik] Yes.
- Oh, so sorry.
My internet is not stable here
because in my ear it's raining.
So I miss many parts of the conversation.
I don't know where I should start.
Just let me briefly
add to the conversation
about the violence and nonviolence.
Some international
community might think that
the way democracy movement
in Myanmar is only violent.
(indistinct) Violence.
They feel that these two ways
could be more effective to...
But, that could be true.
But on the other hand what
we have to think is that
the suffering of the...
The civilians, people,
those who do not join in this armed group.
Like for example, now
in Mindat, my hometown,
and then (indistinct).
Because of this violent fight
many civilians left their hometown.
Like for example, Thantlang in Chin state,
only 28 people stayed in their town.
And the rest of the people
they just fled to jungles,
and some of them (indistinct).
And so what I can say here is that,
violence could be a good way
to defeat this dictatorship,
but we also need to consider the suffering
of those innocent people.
In that case, I really don't know how the
international community could
do some help more effectively.
That might be my additions.
- Let me just turn things
over as moderator to Erik,
since as Erik knows I have
to leave promptly at once.
So thank you all for coming.
And I turn the moderator
role over to Erik.
Thank you.
- Thanks Jim.
David's point there brings
us to a nice transition
to some of the questions in here
about non-violent responses,
or other diplomatic responses.
There was a question from Paul Sarno about
sanctions towards the MOGE,
which I assume is a gas and
electric, or a ministry.
And there's also one that
follows immediately from that,
from Mo Tusar about the ASEAN dialogues,
in the ASEAN summits in October.
And about whether Biden should sit down
with the Min Aung Hlaing.
I think we can talk about
both of those together
as alternative strategies...
That may, or may not be
combined with what's happening
internal to Myanmar,
and it's an armed
resistance in some sense.
But what are some of
the other possible negotiating strategies,
or forms of pressure that
might be put on to the Junta?
Maybe Scot, I'll ask you
to start that conversation,
but again, not leave it
all on your shoulders.
- Thanks, I appreciate that Erik.
Again, I certainly can't speak
for the US government on this.
(indistinct) On attending
the ASEAN meetings.
But I can say in previous discussions,
internal US governments
discussions that I was a part of,
some years ago on sanctions.
The approach generally was to look at
what's the impact of the sanctions.
In this case the goal is clear,
which is to squeeze the Junta's finances.
The Biden administration
has made that clear
through the actions it's already taken.
The other side of that is
what are the negative
consequences of any sanctions.
And so, in some cases
if you got a really broad sanctions,
you could be harming
a lot of other people.
I would guess in the context of looking at
potential Motegi sanctions, again,
it's a what are the positives,
ie reducing revenue to
the regime, to the Junta.
Versus whatever costs or
downsides there are of that,
and I'm not privy to those
conversations so I don't know
how that's going.
In terms of the president's
potential participation
in the ASEAN meetings.
I think it's really important.
I don't know what the
White House is thinking,
or what it will do, of course.
I think it's important,
this is not just a Myanmar issue,
this is all of Southeast Asia.
Ten countries, 600 million people,
so the president's
participation in those meetings
is really important.
Because of an entire region
that's quite in many ways.
And where I think there's
a strong demand for,
in the region, for the US participation.
Obviously it wouldn't be
any president's first choice
to sit down at a meeting
that includes (indistinct).
If the president does
decide to participate,
I think it's important
not to take that as,
"Oh, he's okay with the Junta."
Clearly we're not, the United States
is not okay with the Junta.
But it is important to look at it
in the context of the overall relationship
with all of Southeast Asia,
not just in the Myanmar context.
- I'd be interested to hear
from the other panelists
about the symbolic meaning of if Biden
were to sit down at the table.
How would that be received among...
People in Myanmar,
members of the NUG and
other affiliated groups
interested in the Myanmar
situation right now,
out of curiosity.
Maybe we could start with Ma Thida.
- Well, I think the, first of all,
I think the international community
should accept the failure
of the five-point consensus.
Regarding the ASEAN intervention.
I think they did, if we
cannot recognize this,
we will end up at the (indistinct)
of ASEAN all the time.
Even though we are the part of ASEAN,
ASEAN, every single country said that
ASEAN cannot guarantee any democracy,
because they are still
struggling by themselves.
So for that reason I think even though
the US intervention is just...
Through the platform of the UN,
or by itself to encourage
more intervention.
True ASEANs will not work.
But at the same time, I think the...
I hope, I seriously do hope,
but it's not very promising.
The current, the UN assembly,
people, the other countries, should also
seriously think about their
role for the intervention,
not just US.
Because somehow, for example...
We still do need to take
account for the intervention
from the China and Russia.
Because the people-to-people relationship
among the Myanmar and
China is very, very...
Obvious.
My concern is they are a cover
of a diplomatic relationship,
it's sometimes it's purely the GDG.
And this kind of things
cannot work properly,
because the GDG pressure will
only affect on the SAC,
the Tatmadaw.
Because it's turned out to be
like the current government.
But what we do need is more intervention
through the other platform,
P to P, people to people.
Through the civil society organizations,
through the academy
institution, so and so.
So in that case, ASEAN is
also another big challenge,
because the most of the ASEAN countries
turn out to be the refuge area
for the military families members too.
So in that case, I think the...
The pressure from the other
countries, including US,
towards the ASEAN countries is not to
become part of the refuge.
Police for the military officers
in terms of the legal immigration status.
Or the other other way,
economic investment,
something like that.
We should think about some
other ways to make the...
Pressure on the ASEAN itself.
So, first of all, we need
to acknowledge the failure
of the five-point consensus.
It's already gone from my eyes.
So we should think about a new strategy,
and the solution, not
just through only ASEAN.
Then we should build up the
more
cooperative and collective
solutions through more countries,
not just ASEAN.
- Thank you.
Tun, did you want to add to this?
- I could if I...
Unlock.
I think the...
What Ma Thida said is a very eloquent
in terms of how useful ASEAN
would be for the United States.
If Biden administration want
to create another platform,
we need to really reconsider,
not based on that five-point
diplomatic attempt,
it started out.
But it has to be a different format.
But from the point of view
of the people inside Burma,
CDM participant, the protestor themselves,
and the citizen themselves.
They have no really big hope
in times of international intervention.
They understand it.
But the only thing that they want is the
international community support
national unity government,
which is the elected government of Burma.
November 8th, 2020 elected
government of Burma or Myanmar.
And that government should be,
for international community,
easy to support.
The UN is now under way with the UNGA.
It is recently just yesterday,
it's a schedule that
(indistinct) about to speak.
Give a speech on September
27th was set aside
because the credit share
committee is dealing with
sensitive political
issue within (indistinct)
on the Burma question.
It is really a shame for the UN
not to be able to bravely support
the elected government of Burma.
The United Nations security council
should at least now begin to table
substantive discussion and
maybe have taken action
on the economic and (indistinct) goal.
Especially (indistinct) goal,
against the military regime.
So these framework could be discussed.
If Biden want to create a
new framework with ASEAN,
that's the first thing that
United States have to state
is a baseline.
The baseline is as ambassador
Marciel have already indicated
that current military
leadership made outline,
and the top SAC member
has to be set aside.
They need to step out of it,
a new generation of military leader.
If Biden want to sort of
create that framework,
if ASEAN want to create that framework.
But it is really for the Myanmar public,
it is impossible to
accept even to that level.
Due to what Ma Thida has eloquently stated
about the level of trust
to this institution.
I think we are dealing with
the traditionally state centric politic
that the world is used to.
And here a very important politic
that is defined by the public in Burma.
Never been before in the world,
that we are seeing such
a scale of resilient,
robust population that is
against their own state.
And so this question was never posed
on the world institution,
since the founding of the
United Nation in 1945.
The United Nation need to rethink,
in that rethinking process
we need to consider
those kinds of state sovereignty.
All of the (indistinct),
just war, intervention.
Chapter six and seven are
laid out for a reason,
we know that.
UN charter, chapter six and seven.
These are all elements to rethink
for the international
diplomatic community.
And all the United State department,
this as a global affair
that's moving forward
with some sort of
element that ASEAN leader
might maybe listen.
But hopeless, ASEAN is a
very hopeless institution,
because Malaysia, Singapore and Indonesia
are three respectable countries,
in terms of the freedom of individuals.
The human rights violation and all that.
Other than that, there are not much.
So that would be my two cents.
- We have a couple more minutes left.
We were planning to end at 1:15,
we can go for a few minutes beyond that.
But there's two questions...
That are a little bit more specific,
but one of them builds
from the UN discussion
that we were just talking
about, representation in the UN.
And there's another
aspect of representation
about the refugees in Mizoram
that's raised by Zoma.
And I wondered if you could speak to that,
but maybe think a little bit more broadly
about the representation issue.
And people who are leaving Myanmar
for various purposes and what
can be done to support them.
And then, there's another
question after that,
that I hope we can turn to,
about speculations on
the military logistics
of the actual opposition groups.
Do they have a chance?
And so I'd like to talk to that.
And I think we may run
out of time at that point,
but we'll see where we get.
David, you haven't spoken
since the last time.
Do you want to start this one...
About representation of refugees, perhaps?
- India is slightly
different from Myanmar,
because they have the federal rule.
For example, many Chin
people fled to Mizoram,
and Mizoram have their own way of
making the decisions to welcome them.
That's good news.
And I would like to express
some of the Myanmar people
who joined this panel.
Thank you all for welcoming those,
especially Chin and Kachin people,
for welcoming them in your home state.
I really don't know,
since this has more to do
with the UN recommendations
of the refugees.
I really don't know whether
I might have some insight,
perhaps, I think Scot Marciel
might have more insight about that.
- Go ahead Scot, if you'd like to jump in.
- Okay, I'm certainly not
an expert on this issue,
but I would like to say two things.
First, on the UN I know we all,
we tend to think of the UN as some
independent or institution.
And it is in a way,
you have the Secretary
General and his staff.
But fundamentally,
so you have UN organizations
that work directly for
the Secretary General.
For example, managing the
refugee issue and so on.
But when the UN, when you talk
about the General Assembly,
or the Security Council.
It's a collection of countries,
it's not that when the
UN Security Council,
or General Assembly fails to do something,
it's not the UN per se.
It's because a block of countries says no,
and it's important to keep that in mind.
On the refugee issue...
Generally the UN High
Commissioner for refugees
and his agency will seek access to people
ho have fled, who are seeking asylum.
It depends on the host
countries willingness
to let the UN interview them.
And then the UN would interview them,
UN experts would interview them
and determine whether they have,
whether they qualify for refugee status.
To say it's, technical
issue sounds so impersonal,
but it's the UN does individual
decisions on those refugees
are based on certain criteria.
But the key is for the UN
high commissioner for refugees
to be granted access by
whichever country is hosting,
in this case, it would
be Thailand and India.
And so, that's really where that stands.
And I don't know what
discussions are going on
between the UN and the
government of India,
and the government of Thailand.
I'm sure there are lots
of discussions happening,
but I'm just not privy to them.
- Well, as far as I know
the situation of the refugee status,
waiting either in India or
Thailand is more or less
directly related to the
recognition of the NUG.
They having asked a lot of people
who are looking for the refugee status,
they have been asked
whether they supported
the NUG statement on the September 7th.
And the interpretation of their
statements from some agency
is more or less like supporting violence.
But as far as I understand the statements
by NUG on the September 7th is
saying the state of emergency, that's all.
This is the state of emergency,
but some of the domestic
and international media
also interpret that as the
D-Day for the UMP revolution,
something like that.
That's why some of the
international agency interpreted,
and then they asked
the refugee applicants,
saying that if you support
the statements by NUG
on the 7th of September,
are you supporting violence?
Something like that.
I think the whole ideological conflict
and understanding about the
struggle of our revolution
by the international community.
This is very, pretty much, very important
and the pretty much impactful.
That's why these
counted...
The interpretation, and the...
Reflecting on the media not as if
its
the original document set.
So be more...
Try to dig enough what's really going on,
and what's the meaning of the statements.
And the status of the
NUG should be recognized
not by this statement.
That's my thought.
- Thank you.
We just have two or three more minutes,
and I'd like to end.
although it may be a sobering
way to end the conversation,
but there is this question
from (indistinct).
About the PDF's relative inexperience
in military logistics.
And this concern about its ability
to prevail over the Tatmadaw.
I would be interested in hearing this.
After we speak about this,
what I will do is then stop the recording
and we can have an open
conversation for those
who wish to stick around for
another ten minutes after that.
but maybe we can make this
the final formal response
to a panel discussion.
And...
Maybe Katun you could
start with your response.
- Wow (chuckles).
The UNHC question I would
like to connect to this,
respond to this question.
If UNHC are...
If they can function within (indistinct),
and working with (indistinct).
If they cannot send their own personnel's,
this is a time to actually
to be brave and bold.
If they want to really
help the situation inside,
there are internally displaced people.
As David already said
the city in Chin state
has only 28 residents left.
Where did they go, how do we help them?
Right?
Of course, to the India.
And then other area
within Myanmar as well.
With that,
also the question of how do we...
Can you rephrase a
little bit that question?
I did not read that question Erik,
if you don't mind.
- Yeah, the question is basically
does the opposition group
have a chance of prevailing
over the Tatmadaw.
It's a military question
in a sense to say,
if it turns to full violent resistance,
what are the chances of winning?
- Thank you, I think
the convention of war,
they are well-prepared, the
military is well-prepared.
And what the PDF and others are imagining,
are a war of attrition
type, attrition war.
Which is although what broader sense
of international economic
sanctions, and so on.
Try to chip away the power of the existing
authority anti-government.
These are in line with
that kind of thinking,
I think if they engage
in such kind of war.
And at the same time, if they engage with
some of the low-level
soldiers within the military,
start up conversation with them.
And what the Chin, and CNF, and UG,
has been recently offering them
some sort of reward;
Financial and safety for them,
if they want to join the public
and in a peaceful CDM way.
If they can empty out,
which is although the
intention of CDM movement,
the civil servants who wanted
to cripple the function
of the military council.
And who want to actually don't see
that military council's
government properly working
as an authoritarian government.
CDM has that intention and so
they can sort of work with PDF
and the NUG can work with,
which they are already beginning to.
If that combined with what PDF are doing,
I think it is a just war.
It is just, if you are
taking down the airplanes
and trucks in Mytel tower.
Which will be used by the
military to kill its own people.
They are not attacking people,
civilian or the military men here,
they are just basically taking away,
like Kachin, KIA has started way back.
In the gasoline truck
coming in from China,
destroying them on the road,
letting the driver flee.
All kinds of these
kinds of peaceful action
that they are doing a type of
war, attrition if you will.
And that kind of war, and
strategy well-coordinated,
will be, I think, quite useful
for making the military,
especially low-level
soldier all the way to maybe
regional commander level to join the CDM.
And then empty out the military
institution at the top,
who will not change
their mind at this point.
And they have so much
stake in their families,
like Ma Thida was saying,
their future, their businesses, and so on.
If NUG and PDF can orchestrate that,
and (indistinct) what they were doing.
So what I'm saying is there
a broader type of activity
is needed to really win this war.
And that of course need to be detail out.
So for instance, military soldier
who are ordered to shoot on the street.
They can point it into the round duration,
and instead of shooting people,
they can shoot it to other people.
And so that kind of military man's,
their own internal resistant
against their own leaders order.
Making sure that their trucks,
the wire is not working,
the battery is not
charged, and the gasoline
is not enough to arrive
from point A to point B.
Military men if they wanted to join CDM
in such a way from inside
without taking off uniform,
and they can do so.
And these kinds of
mechanism can be implemented
with the coordination
of NUG PDF strategies,
and communication with these potential CDM
thinking military men.
If that kind of war,
if that kind of strategy
can be structured,
I think there's a chance of winning.
If you are going out to conventional war,
who know?
A flight from China with military
men on the side may come,
that's a very sobering
international relation,
security imagination I'm thinking here.
I don't mean to say it could
happen or it will happen,
but it is possibility there, right?
So all the way to the support from China,
and possibly the Russian military,
then maybe some Israeli
communication equipment
that are making money out
of this kind of a crisis
in the world for a long time.
These kinds of things had
to be really orchestrated
in thinking process and
structuring the war that
NUG might be intending to do.
I do not know exactly
what they are thinking.
That would be where I would leave.
- Thank you.
If anyone has a short final comment,
I'd love to hear that.
And then I'll bring it to a close,
and then we'll have an
informal discussion afterward.
Any final comments?
- Well, I think the formal intention
of this armed resistance is...
As the military have only
the language of weapons,
they have no other language.
For that reasons, the revolutions...
Groups, decided to make sure
the military started listening to them
with this arms struggle.
And the final position
will be on the table
by the (indistinct) leaders.
That's the real intention
from the very beginning
for the UMP revolution, I think.
- Okay, well, thank you everyone
for this fascinating conversation.
It's really the beginning of what I think
will be a long series of conversations
about these complex issues.
But most importantly,
I want to thank you all for joining us.
And please everyone in attendance
join me in thanking the panelists.
Thank you very much.